welcome to day one at the Paris Opera
ballet school I can't believe I'm
actually here
good morning everyone there's been some
sort of administrative error you will
all re-audition for your place at the
Paris Opera ballet
good luck
[Music]
she looks like a lost alpaca
what if I don't make the cut they're
going to send me home
wow can't believe your mum owns
wpothecary
what's that just some W recipes I guess
hey why do you call your W recipe book
the book of Jones it's the book of
family spells you're a witch not just me
you we call ourselves Wizards come on
your magic is special you're one of us
we need you to start training now that's
what I'm doing at school
your Birthright it's not something you
can walk away from weird because that's
exactly what I'm doing see walking
no CeCe stop off to the side CeCe you
have to believe you can dance
I know I'm good enough
[Music]
focusing on dance and only dance is the
only way this is going to happen you do
realize that
Double Double Toil in trouble
[Music]
all the Wizards have been waiting for
you I have to focus on staying at this
school not saving the freaking world
wait until you see what I have planned
[Music]